People are describing Avengers: Endgame as
a mind-blowing achievement in filmmaking,
a love letter to the fans, and a flawless
culmination of the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe thus far.
it's mostly been positivity all around for
Marvel Studios' 22nd movie "mostly" being
the operative word here.
Reviews from critics are stellar, with the
film scoring Certified Fresh distinction on
Rotten Tomatoes less than 24 hours after the
review embargo lifted, but response from some
fans has been considerably less so… and
that's putting it lightly.
If you want to find out what it is some people
are so mad about, no worries there are no
spoilers here.
Apparently, many Marvel enthusiasts are angry
at Avengers: Endgame over one thing: it doesn't
feature a post-credits scene.
Shocking news, we know, as it's customary
in the MCU for each installment to cap off
with at least one sequence after the credits
have rolled, whether it's a portentous tease
for movies to come or a humorous tag to leave
you laughing as the movie ends.
I'm not that kind of doctor.
I'm not a therapist.
It's not my training.
I don't have the—"
"What, the time?"
"Temperament."
While some movies in the series have had as
many as five little scenes during the credits,
Avengers: Endgame has zero, much to the outrage
and confusion of some fans across the globe.
If you waited for a thousand names to scroll
by and got nothing in return for it, you might
be a little ticked off too.
"Hi — I'm Captain America, here to talk
to you about one of the most valuable traits
a soldier or student can have — patience."
After several sources confirmed that Endgame
goes without a single scene to cap things
off, and following the international debut
of the film earlier this week, fans took to
social media to lodge complaints and express
bewilderment.
Along with a pair of frowning face emojis,
one Twitter user by the name of Roschelle
Apa said,
"I'm actually emotional over the fact that
#AvengersEndGame won't have any post-credits
scene[s].
It's the end of an era, y'all."
Another admitted that he, quote, "waited like
an idiot" for 15 minutes after Endgame was
over, hoping for a mid- or post-credits scene
to play out on screen.
He advised that everyone not make the same
mistake he did, though he did acknowledge
"The huge team that made the movie tho fire"
There were many more moviegoers who weren't
aware that no additional footage would screen
after Endgame.
User Andy Belluna explained that an entire
theater full of people were irritated when
they made the realization:
"The movie has no post-credits scene, but
we didn't know, so the whole cinema sat still
and waited through the credits just to see
a black screen afterwards.
Everyone was SO pissed and absolutely done
with their lives."
On the flip side, one fan who saw the film
already explained that no one in her screening
actually got up after the movie was over,
despite knowing that a post-credits scene
wasn't coming.
She wrote on Twitter,
"As reported, there's no extra footage after
the credits (it's true), everybody knew it
and also the cinema staff told us, but nobody
left.
I told them it's not that we don't trust you,
we're just too shook to move."
Other fans, perhaps having been burned by
missing out before, have sworn not to leave
their theater seats until the projector stops
running and the lights flicker back on.
As one Twitter user put it,
"Even if [the Russo brothers themselves] say
there are no post credit scenes, I'm not outta
my seat until the last line roll out on screen.
What if it's a trap.."
They also appended the hashtag, "Things Marvel
Fans Are Used To."
Considering that Marvel Studios has previously
gone so far as to give cast members fake scripts
to keep spoilers at bay, manipulate trailers
to show shots not in the movie, and put actors
together for scenes that aren't real to fake
out paparazzi, fans' paranoia about being
tricked is somewhat well-founded.
So it's no surprise that speculation has emerged
that Marvel could slip in a post-credits scene
to Endgame screenings starting on Thursday,
April 25, giving general audiences a little
something that early overseas showings and
press screenings didn't.
This would somewhat mirror what 20th Century
Fox did with Deadpool: advanced screenings
did include a post-credits scene, but the
theatrical cut featured an extended sequence
that included the juicy information that Cable
would appear in the sequel.
Additionally, the first Avengers movie also
included an extra shawarma scene that was
shot and edited into the movie after its world
premiere had already happened.
And not to keep you guessing, but we are actually
not done shooting.
We are shooting one more scene…" *gasps*
"...tonight."
Those precedents might be reason enough to
believe that fans heading to see Endgame as
early as Thursday night could experience what
others haven't yet.
Of course, it's just hearsay for now, but
it's something to be aware of as you dart
out for the bathroom after three punishing
hours of superhero mayhem.
If that doesn't happen and Avengers: Endgame
truly does continue to conclude right before
the credits, it wouldn't be all that bad.
It could act as a reminder that Endgame is
different from any MCU movie that came before
it.
As the saying goes, all good things must come
to an end even Marvel's post-credits-scene
tradition.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.